♪ Super Sonic ♪
- Good morning, my rural chum!
- Mister?
- Doctor Robotnik.
I'm going to give you five seconds
to tell me where it is.
- Wait, don't hurt him!
(screaming)
- So first of all,
earlier on this year at CinemaCon,
you said that you liked,
you really liked playing
Robotnik for a couple of reasons.
You said you got to explore
a new side of yourself
and hit the absurd energy people love.
- Yeah.
- So I'm wondering,
what did you find out about
yourself playing this role?
- I'm not that smart.
(Nikki laughing)
- Anybody by comparison.
- I'm not that great
at video games.
(laughing)
But the wonderful thing about it is,
I can be really lousy at this video game
and still win because I'm Robotnik.
- You are the most--
- So literally.
- Evil person in the world.
- When I see
the big machine Robotnik coming by,
I just ram Sonic into him.
- Yes.
- Over and over again until he goes.
(laughing)
Flies off the game grid.
- He's such an iconic character.
- Yeah.
- Beloved by the Sonic OGs.
- And you've played
so many iconic characters.
So how did you approach Robotnik?
- Basically, I,
I believe that light,
you and I don't have to believe it,
it's true scientifically.
Lightning starts from the ground.
So that's the same with the character,
with this kinda character,
is like I had to find that
evil genius,
the combination of absolute intelligence
and total worthlessness in his own mind.
That combination is deadly
and we're seeing a lot of it.
We're seeing a lot of it.
- That also sounds
like Hollywood.
- It sounds like billionaires.
- [Nikki] Yes.
- It's not Hollywood.
It's everywhere, it's everywhere.
So that's a wonderful combination to play
plus the idea of AI
freaking everybody out.
- [Nikki] Yeah.
- They're putting chips in people's heads
and Alexa is spying on you
and watching you and saying,
"You might wanna change your underwear."
- I know in the film,
to sort of display Sonic's speed.
- Yeah.
- They have everything else
freeze around him 'cause he's so quick.
- Right.
- Your humor is so quick.
When you are in a scene
is everything frozen around you?
What do you experience
when you're going at lightning speed?
- Everybody's dumbfounded.
- Everybody's, "Err."
- Well generally,
generally it goes,
the world spins for me.
It's wild.
My world is a game grid.
And I look at it like
every little segment,
every little moment,
like this moment with you
is the only thing that is, right?
And then there's something else
and then the next moment
is the only thing that is.
And I try to completely dedicate
myself to those moments.
And bring whatever I can to those moments.
And in the same way when I perform,
I'm in my hotel room,
I'm walking in a circle,
I'm saying the lines to
myself, and I learn them.
And then my brain starts creating
and screws up all my learning
and the next thing you
know, I've dreamt about it,
I'm walking, over breakfast.
I have some ideas, and then
I come in with 20 new ideas,
a third of which I can remember.
The rest are on little
cards tied up everywhere.
And--
- Your hotel rooms
must look really cool.
- It's like,
(laser beam zapping)
(laughing)
Whatever's in my consciousness.
Whatever gets my attention
becomes part of the show.
- So Sonic has a bucket
list in this movie.
Are you, because you do
what you're just saying,
just living in the moment.
Do you have a bucket list?
Are there things that you really wanna do?
- I wanna explode into a ball of light.
- Do you?
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- That's big.
- That's a big one.
- Number one.
- Yes.
- Then there's nothing else
comes after that?
- Yeah.
I wanna awaken spiritually
over and over again.
And then go back to sleep.
(laughing)
And hit the snooze alarm.
- Right.
Is there something you've accomplished,
something bucket list-ish
that you have done?
- I am literally black
and blue with pinch marks,
from my life.
It is a constant surprise.
A constant
just a gratitude soup.
Honest to God.
Every bite of it, I just go,
"I can't believe I'm here.
"I can't believe I get to do what I do."
I love my audience.
I love what I do.
And I get to do not only that,
I get to produce a TV show and star on it.
I get to
write a novel/memoir
that's coming out in May.
I get to,
become a cartoonist and an artist
and actually be taken seriously that way
and contribute in New York
and Playboy Magazines.
It is an embarrassment of
riches and opportunities
and prosperity and abundance.
And I honestly,
I feel like I'm,
and I say this all the time,
I talk about mangoes.
I look at it like life
has just become a gigantic mango tree.
And I'm sitting underneath it
and they're just falling all around me,
and it's wonderful.
- You made a joke about your haircut,
how it took seven haircuts to grow out.
- Yes.
- So I wanted to say
from women everywhere
who have had bad haircuts.
(laughing)
We fully appreciate
what you've gone through.
_ Yeah.
Well they cut that,
that part into my hair.
It was a nice big thick swath
and it screwed everything up.
They wanted it to be seen
from outer space or something.
I don't know.
- So you understand
what women go through.
- Oh, yes.
I can't say I totally understand
but yes.
- Thank you.
- I empathize.
- Yes.
- Oh my god, stop the car right now!
- What? What?
- The world's largest
rubber band ball?
We gotta see it.
- No, this is not some
fun family road trip!
- Eh, you're right.
It was lame.
Gift shop was cool though.
(thudding)
- This is a movie reference.
People have to see the
movie to understand this.
Although it is in the trailer.
- It is.
- A little bit.
- If you go to Fandango's
Twitter, it's there.
- There.
You're on our Twitter too
'cause you retweeted us.
Thank you.
- I know, I was very excited.
You posted a clip today
that although I don't
know when it's coming out.
But you posted a clip.
How do you do it?
You do it this way?
- I do it that way
but I'm Canadian.
(laughing)
- So you do it a totally different way?
- I don't know.
- You posted
a clip today that, oh.
Oh, you posted.
- You're very good at it.
- Yeah.
- I actually shortened
your string so you'd be better than me.
(laughing)
- You posted a clip today
and I was so excited you did
because it's this speech
but there's a line in it
that I tried to copy
Jim Carrey's performance
in "Dumb and Dumber."
- Stop it.
- So there's a line that he
does in "Dumb and Dumber"
where he's like,
he's talking about this thing,
and then he goes, "Our pets'
heads are falling off!"
- We got no food!
We got no jobs!
Our pets' heads are fallin' off!
- And I did that for this.
I go, "I got a fish on my head!"
- I'm wet.
I'm cold.
There's a fish on my head!
- We had fans pick their
most iconic Sonic lines.
The OG fans.
- Are you kidding me?
You need glasses.
You went like this to read that?
- No, I want you to do it.
- Oh.
Okay, so you want--
- I don't wanna do the voice.
- You want me to do Sonic?
- Yes.
- Okay.
Okay.
You might know everything I'm gonna do
but that's not gonna help you.
Since I know everything you're gonna do.
Strange isn't it.
(laughing)
I found you, faker!
I'll make you eat those words!
You're too slow!
And what's this one?
Fandango's great.
That's not from a cartoon show.
- You are the master improver
'cause that was not on the,
that was not on the card.
- Oh wow.
Oh my goodness.
- Wow.
That just, that was incredible
watching that.
- Want me to keep this?
- You can keep it.
- Oh really?
- And the paddle board.
- Okay.
- It's incredible watching it
because it's hard to do.
It's really hard to do
but you've done a couple of voices before.
So how did you change it up for this one?
And did you pay homage to the originals?
How did you?
- Sure.
- Yeah.
- So there've been
incredible voiceover actors
that have done this voice.
- Yeah.
- There's Roger Craig,
there's Jaleel, there's
Ryan, there's Jason.
There's a long list of incredible people.
And people who've done Robotnik, man.
There's some great
Robotnik voices out there.
But the way that I did it was
I played the video games one more time
and then I read the script and in my head,
the way that the script played was like,
it like this young kid
who has so much energy,
who's never been allowed out of this cave,
finally gets out of this cave,
gets to do whatever he
does and he's so excited.
So I kind of just played
it like a little kid
that's finally so excited to
do whatever he wanted to do.
And it just happens to look like that.
So when you're watching the movie,
you feel the warmth and connection
between Tom and this character
'cause it feels like a real little boy.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- That's kinda where I was coming from.
- Wow, I love that.
- Oh, great.
- And playing the video game.
That wasn't really research, was it?
You just wanted to.
- Oh no.
I remember literally when I got the role,
I was like, "Oh, I can write off
"that I've already bought
Sonic Mania, I guess.
"Now it's a business expense?"
Something like that.
- 'Cause there's a lot of talk
about bucket list in this movie.
So did you check off a bucket list item
playing Sonic?
- For many things.
One, which is to be Sonic,
a character that I've loved growing up.
The other one, to be in a
movie that stars Jim Carrey.
That's something that--
- Yeah.
- If you asked me as a kid,
I couldn't even dream that big.
I never thought I'd be doing any of this.
I was a psych-anthro major.
So the idea that any of this is happening
is above and beyond.
I feel very very lucky.
- So I know you're a gamer.
You're a huge gamer.
- I am a gamer.
- So for the OG Sonic fans,
what are they gonna find in this movie
that they're gonna love?
- I mean I could tell
you specific Easter eggs,
if you want.
- Go for it.
- Okay, there's some
Easter eggs in the game.
There's one that if you're
Sonic and you go near ledge,
he goes like this.
In the movie, in the
hotel scene there's that.
If you look at his bandana,
when he playing with his nunchucks,
the old emblem of the
start screen is there,
and there's a bunch of different ones
that I won't talk about now.
But I think what,
the cool thing that Jeff and all,
everybody did and the writers did,
is that they reward the fans
that have been there for a while
with all these fun Easter eggs.
And they help introduce Sonic
in a way that if you've
never seen this before,
you still get to love it
'cause it's got action, comedy,
drama, heart, Jim Carrey.
And it comes together in
this fun beautiful way.
- Clearly, I'm not gonna be
able to do this on my own.
(fish sloshing)
(thudding)
(sighing)
- All right.
Get in the truck.
- Really?
You're gonna help me?
- I guess it is a little bit my fault
that all this is happening to you.
- Not a little bit.
Entirely!
It is entirely your fault.
- Okay.
It's entirely my fault.
Are you coming?
- Yes.
(door thudding)
Road trip, whoop whoop!
- What am I doing?
- [Nikki] So this opens
on Valentine's Day.
- That's right.
- It's such a
counterintuitive to Valentine's Day
but why is this the perfect
Valentine's weekend movie?
- Why is it?
Because I think that at the
core of every good relationship
is a friendship.
(snorting)
- That was brilliant!
(laughing)
- I actually do believe that.
- Yeah.
- But yeah.
Maybe for all the people
who don't wanna do this
sort of straight down the line,
what you're supposed to
do on Valentine's Day.
Go see a fun movie that you
can both laugh at together.
Laugh at.
- This movie is so,
laugh with.
- Yes.
- Laugh alone.
Cry alone on Valentine's.
- Yes, get a laugh at it.
- Whatever.
- Laugh at it.
Laugh all you want, laugh it.
Every preposition you can think of.
- So you are so phenomenal in this movie.
- Oh, thank you, thank you.
- And what I always do,
whenever I watch a movie
that has CGI characters,
I'm looking for the cracks.
I'm looking for when
the actor, I can tell.
- Same.
- There's no CGI.
Do you do the same thing?
- I do the same thing, yes.
- I couldn't see any with you.
- That was my goal.
I was like, I want to make them
feel like this is real,
and sometimes the camera
operators will be like,
"Ah, just look over here."
I'm like, "No no no.
"I wanna know exactly where his eyes are."
'Cause you can tell
if you're looking 15 feet in the distance
or two feet, right?
- Yeah.
- Your eyes triangulate.
Anyway, well good.
I'm glad you feel the same way.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
So just also for you,
when you're on the day,
did you have voices?
Did they play voices?
Did you play against the sound?
- Yes, there was a gentleman there
who was a really talented and funny guy
who was reading opposite me.
But he was hidden that
I couldn't hear him.
He knew,
he got the sense of Ben's sensibilities
and his comic timing,
and he was a great help
when Ben wasn't there,
so that there was someone
reading the lines with you
and created the rhythm of the scene.
But as far as something to
look at, it was nothing.
There was no,
I tried to get Ben in a full
blue spandex suit there.
(laughing)
- That would have been great.
- But he was busy
and too tall, it turns out.
- Right.
That would've been great
for the extras on the DVD.
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
Maybe, maybe there will be.
- So I know you're a bit of a gamer
or at least you were a bit of a gamer.
What do you think the OG fans of Sonic
are gonna appreciate about this movie?
- I think they're gonna love,
'cause look, there's a certain,
there's a certain mythology with the game
and certain lore
that we expanded upon to
make it a film, right?
So the storyline, some
of those things weren't,
Sonic never spoke in
the video games, right?
And suddenly now Ben
Schwartz is voicing him.
But I think the fans who
grew up playing the game
are gonna love seeing the
character come to life.
He now has a voice.
He now has a personality.
He's cocky, he sorta, he sarcastic
but there's an innocence, a purity to him.
And it's like,
anybody who loved something growing up
that existed in a two-dimensional world,
seeing it step into the 3rd
dimension and come to life.
- Something about your childhood.
When you were--
- Yeah, hearing the ching
of when he gets the rings.
- Yes.
- All those nostalgic
markers that just make you happy
and that bring you back to your childhood.
- For you, what were those games?
Was it Sonic?
And what are the other ones
that maybe would make a great movie?
- Yeah, that's a good question.
I was like 18 or 19 when Sonic came out.
I was still video gaming.
But I started with Atari
and computer games like
an old Commodore 64
and the television and
Nintendo and Super Nintendo.
I spent, the games I
spent the most time on
were probably the original Mario Brothers,
Sonic,
and GoldenEye.
- Love it!
- Yeah, GoldenEye.
That was the first first-person
shooter kinda thing
and I spent way too
many hours playing that.
I had to quit.
I had to quit all video games.
- Did you really?
- Yeah.
'Cause I just would get sucked,
I would just not get anything done
and I would just get sucked in
and four hours would pass like that.
So I have a great place in
my heart for video gamers,
for video games period.
Sonic is one of the
great iconic characters.
So it's a special thing to
bring him to the big screen.
(upbeat rock music)
- [Robotnik] Whatever this creature is
I'm going to uncover the
source of its powers.
Yeah, hey!
(upbeat rock music)